[Musik]
heute wird sie denn tief verstört
milliarden bei manager befindet sich
gerade im zimmer nebenan und wir beiden
wenngleich zum stadion des 1 fc köln für
an der liga ein sich wandelndes fc köln
ist doch warum fahren wir zum stadion
für das epische finale wollen uns auf
jeden fall so ein fünftel wisst was ich
meine
[Musik]
was ist das da vorne es ist der ort an
dem wir gleich gewinnen wirst korrekter
möbeln aber wir spielen darin fifa es
geht nicht um energie es geht um den
rhein
es geht darum dass tore fallen und zwar
für mich was laberst du herzlich
willkommen fifa mit sebastian wird
verlieren und dass darin die frage ist
was ich mir wirklich ganz stelle sind
wir hätten sogar schon eine verhältnis
klar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kalter wo sind deine der frauen ich
glaube ich ist meine ultras wir haben
elf tickets verkauft ohne endeten die
wollen alle sehen
hier gewinnt unterdessen ja genau
die warten nur noch regelrecht darauf
dass wissen die katakomben gehen uns
umziehen und duschen aus dem statistik
wird das hier geht es nach unten
18 drauf wie waffeln oder
weihnachtsmusik gleich oben
ab in die lounge
hier hat er aussicht kuba lukas podolski
klose
immer genau in shops sieht so aus als
würde zu verlieren oder nicht sagen ab
wann die controller kommt jetzt wird
hier in gewinner sind im spiel losgeht
vor allem ich schön hier im trikot des 1
fc köln unterwegs
es geht um die wurst ok service bereit
ich bin halt herum ist es unsicher
geht er die luxus geht hier ein bisschen
auf weil wir sind freunde wir sehen
schon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dahinter wurden fast 14 minuten an der
anfang haben wir der anfrage kommt ab
jährigen ryan ab hinten rund 6 nachts
müssen zu halten
schönes ding ok schönen tackling com
alaba hat widerspricht nach vorne kommen
junge kks es geht erstmal im vorwärts
marsch milliarden euro leichte aufgabe
für die abwehr
egal was macht er was ist denn los
jungen sie führt 1 0 und sicherste hand
geben unternehmen und immobilien
hast du dich gerade weil posten wir ja
wohl kosten als junger freunde ich nicht
immer hinten interest liegt immerhin
noch nein
ja
[Musik]
yeah
jahrhundert älter und wieder habe ich
bei dem gebraucht vier minuten
aufzuholen schauen wie lange ich jetzt
auch einmal ganz engem raum zum verkauf
auf einmal wenig effektiv plötzlich
freunde die lose führt 2 zu 1 23 minute
auch junge warum hältst du denn hin
sollen traurig bestiegen hat im regel
freundlich selbst gewählten weg ist auch
gerade deswegen haben uns gedacht mein
gott es gab verletzte
die kriegsangst angezeigt doch warum
bekommen wir den sonnenschutz bei rum
was er kommt wisse jetzt das 2 1 über
die zeit bringt eine neue so krank ist
daran denkst dir geht's gut ich mache
die fehler dann ist vielleicht auch eine
chance also die anspannung ist riesig
freunde wir spielen ja gerade im
rheinenergiestadion in köln es ist nur
ein herz fasst und horst bei mir auch
wenn die auch hamburger heuer war okay
kommt du hast auch neuer wirst du die
ganzen coins wir haben ein ganzes team
kostet ungelogen fragen der mein ganzes
team kostet 600.000 wieder habe ich gar
nichts mit david und ich habe den ring
gesehen aber ich merke schon ich werde
ganz nach hinten gedrängt
euro
zweimal posten kommt das nicht gerade
einfach umgedreht ist südafrika ich
hatte auch lattenschüsse und alles im
hinspiel jetzt plötzlich genau wie ich
es verloren elfer war meine damen und
herren der sebastian kann sich hier
wirklich nur mit fouls helfen was habe
ich hab noch nie ne wand gemalt ich kann
ja gar nicht so schlimm drei zwei eins
meine damen und herren ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen wenn jetzt noch ein tor
kommt hätte ich noch mal kurz angst aber
ich meine die habe ich allgemein keine
angst von da ist gar kein problem
90 minute sebastian 19 minute die
nächste chance muss rein ansonsten
kannst du das wirklich abhaken kommen
alle aber zieht normale jungs da ist der
sieg da ist er sieht da wird das fest
geworden sie waren sehr nice gespielt
fand ich auf jeden fall treffen gegen
die ich erzähle geworden ich zu haben im
finale kann passieren aber aber ich
würde sagen besser im spiel
zum letzten mal aber ich würde sagen
dass wir am besten mal für die
pressekonferenz oder sehr geehrte
pressevertreter
ich begrüße sie zur offiziellen pk nach
dem spiel luca gegen sk
ich habe mich noch nie so gut gefühlt in
meinem ganzen leben also es gab schon
viele siege die ich tatsächlich schon in
schon hatte und das war leider davon
also ganz normal
eigentlich ja es geht oder hat das
gewesen wenn ich jetzt gerade nicht
angenommen daher ist jetzt ein
abstiegskandidat
was sagen sie denn das geil ja meine
strategie war es zu gewinnen da ich von
der ersten bis zur 90 minute dran
geglaubt und ich glaube dass sich das
auf die mannschaft aus gelegt hatte auf
ein spielverhalten ja also ich denke
verändern haben wir vielleicht so nicht
sagen waren vorher todfeinde das kann
man jetzt noch dazu insofern bleibt
vielleicht hat es gleich deswegen setzt
auch immer zwischen uns das man
maschinen die von karen szola das bei
mir geht's heute gewinner gulasch
zusammen mit dem mit den sieger
salzkartoffeln und wir haben für ihn
noch
legale verlierer also ausreichen
gut gespielt weitere fragen kann ich
sagen die untersuchungen beendet
es hat auf jeden fall ultra viel spaß
gemacht diese ganze fifa kampagne also
die spiele die wir gemacht haben das
erste hat ja sehr viel gewicht gewonnen
das dritte entscheidungsspiel jetzt
etwas schade ich meine vielfach zu ist
jan ist ein übriges geiles spiel
görlich war das spiel ist nur eine
momentaufnahme ist nichts kann ganz
anders ausgehen
an der stelle würde ich den heutigen
blog jetzt allerdings auch beenden ihr
heute ist glaube ich schon an meiner
stimme ich bin ein bisschen heiser ich
bin ein bisschen erkältet deswegen fahre
ich jetzt wieder nach hause machen wir
ein tee und geht dann auch schlafen wenn
euch die glocke gefallen hat man so ein
bisschen was anderes mal ein bisschen
was erlebt hier war passiert nicht so
häufig in einem langweiligen leben
das kann man leichter schreibt mir die
kommentare wir selber fifa spielt und
jetzt ja ist der block vorbei
[Musik]